[Music]
on this tuesday night
grilling the keel burgers the brothers
who co-founded the weed charity face the
finance committee about that
controversial contract
we did this to be of service to the
government and their ties
to the prime minister hanging with their
family come on
the kielburgers say they wish they'd
never accepted the contract in a hearing
full of frustration there will be order
i'll suspend the meeting and that's
it bowing to pressure the public inquiry
just ordered into the nova scotia mass
murders
mandatory masks in a canadian resort
town it can get quite
crowded and squishy the rule that will
apply even
outdoors and pregnancies making waves
we're very happy that she's pregnant
again cautious optimism
for the orca population
[Music]
global national with donna friesen
good evening and thanks for joining us
the brothers at the center of the
controversy over the multi-million
dollar student grant program spent hours
being grilled under oath today
craig and mark kielberger co-founders of
the we charity told mps they agreed to a
contract to administer
a 543 million dollar federal program not
100
912 million which is the figure the
government used and they said they
wanted to make a difference
they said they would not have made any
profit off it
the sole source contract was pulled
after it was revealed members of prime
minister justin trudeau's family were
paid to appear at wii events
his mother margaret got two hundred and
fifty thousand dollars
and the finance minister bill morneau
and his family took two trips with we in
2017
only reimbursing the charity last week
for 41 000
the kielburgers said today they had no
idea how the whole affair
would be perceived we would never
have picked up the phone when the civil
service called
if we had known the consequences the
young people would not get the help they
need now
and the 25 years of we charities
programs
helping millions of youth would be in
jeopardy
the kielburgers used their appearance
before the finance committee to defend
their organization
and deny reports they were in any
financial trouble and that's why they
needed the contract
as abigail beeman reports even after
four hours of
testimony there are still unanswered
questions
no prior consent mr paliad do i have to
suspend this meeting because i will
testimony at times tense as mps pushed
to get all their questions answered
my next question that was well i i i'm
that's right and so i'm not so the floor
is not yours a challenge even though
mark and craig kielberger were in the
hot seat for four
hours we did this to be of service to
the government
not for the government to help us and it
is incredibly unfortunate
the fallout that has occurred the
brothers said they wanted to set the
record straight that they didn't stand
to profit from the deal
long touted by the government to be
worth 912 million dollars
newly released documents mean the total
amount is still unclear
first time we heard about the 912
million was when it was announced um we
had never been
privy to that information before
secondly is that the contract is
up to as you said very correctly the 543
million
they offered some numbers average
expenses paid to the trudeau family for
their appearances
but didn't offer a total saying they'd
provide more documentation later
per event though came to a total of 28
we days
over a span of five years specifically
speaking on the issue of mental health
from 2016 to 2020 the average expense
there was 5998 dollars there were lots
of questions about the we charity
foundation the separate organization the
kielberger say they used to protect
themselves from liability
we were very concerned about the request
that we were asked to take on
a liability for 40 000 young people
don't you get that this looks kind of
dodgy to the average canadian
and the opposition wanted to know why we
isn't registered to lobby
previous up to this point we've had
virtually very limited engagement with
the federal government
seeking funds and they at this point
approach hanging with their family come
on
the opposition were certainly frustrated
i mean these guys are incredibly slick
more unanswered questions around mass
layoffs and a big
board turnover including the chair's
resignation
i did have a number of concerns yes
michelle douglas testified the board
repeatedly asked the executive for
reports to justify those layoffs
but never saw them we were being denied
access to the chief financial officer we
had sought
two meetings with them and they were
both cancelled
four hours of testimony is very unusual
so too is the appearance of a sitting
prime minister at committee
justin trudeau and his chief of staff
will testify
on thursday donna
abigail beeman in ottawa thanks the keel
burgers have a long history
doing charitable work
37 year old craig and older brother mark
are co-founders of we
and call themselves humanitarians and
social entrepreneurs
it started in 1995 when craig was 12
with free the children which focused on
stopping child labor
and expanded to reducing poverty and
improving sanitation and education for
kids
the kielbergers built it into a
worldwide organization
never could have imagined that today 500
schools built
27 000 microcredit cooperatives a
million people we work with around the
world
they wrote best-selling books and built
a powerful brand
forging ties with politicians of all
stripes and with celebrities
in 2008 they launched a for-profit
company called
me to we and became known around the
world for their star-studded we day
events
make some noise for selena gomez
many of the questions now stem not only
from the close ties to the trudeau
family
but from we's complicated organizational
structure
which includes registered charities
for-profit businesses
and holding companies
after intense pressure from the families
of victims of nova scotia's mass
shooting the federal government
announced today there will be
a full public inquiry be a great relief
to everybody
um we're all traumatized of course the
the families of the victims more than
others but
all of us have been through this
together
the move by the government is a big
upgrade from the joint federal
provincial review announced last week
it did not have the power to compel
witnesses to testify
and was denounced by families of the
victims as useless elizabeth mcsheffrey
is with me from halifax elizabeth
why the change now and what will it mean
in terms of getting answers
well as as you've said the the
review that was announced last week was
met with tremendous backlash
here in nova scotia with hundreds of
people marching on the streets in the
last two days
but it really has been the last 24 hours
here that have been so astonishing
it's in the last uh you know this
afternoon we had
five federal liberal mps break the ranks
and call on ottawa to to proceed with a
full public inquiry
and that split in federal unity is what
prompted our justice minister here in
nova scotia
to say that if bill blair decides to go
ahead with a public inquiry
our government here will support that as
well
and a statement now from the public
safety minister's office says the new
inquiry will include the power to summon
all witnesses evidence
and documents deemed necessary to
proceed with the investigation
that means of course folsom
participation from the rcmp
and some answers for nova scotians on
how this atrocity took place and whether
it could have been prevented
we did speak this evening to one of the
families of the victims harry bond lost
both his parents
joy and peter in the attack he says he
learned about this latest news on
facebook
and he's overwhelmed it may it made his
day
uh but he says the family should not
have had to fight for this development
so one thing we'll be watching for in
the days to come is confirmation from
the federal government
that this new transparent process uh
will be able to make binding legal
recommendations
we'll also be watching to make sure that
it's going to include
a close look into how domestic violence
played a role in what happened
and what socio-cultural elements
might have contributed to any of the
shooters motivations for committing this
horrific atrocity
elizabeth mcsheffrey in halifax thanks
now to the pandemic health canada has
approved the antiviral drug
rem deserver to treat patients with
severe symptoms of covid19
it's the first drug to be approved for
that use in canada remdezzavir will only
be given to patients over the age of 12
who have
severe pneumonia symptoms and need
oxygen to breathe
the drug is administered intravenously
and patients are closely monitored
several countries including the united
states have already conditionally
approved rem de severe
access to the drug could be difficult
though the u.s government has purchased
nearly the entire global supply
canada's chief public health officer
said today this country is in
discussions to
access that limited supply dr teresa tam
also shared her concerns about what she
calls the
worrisome trend of canada's covid19
curve
ticking up if we over tax the public
health resources
and lose this ability to effectively
test and trace
well let's not go there
tam is in gain encouraging canadians to
limit their number of social
interactions and to continue
practicing physical distancing and
proper hygiene
wearing a mask is strongly recommended
as another way to reduce the spread of
the virus and many jurisdictions are
making them mandatory in public indoor
spaces
the town of banff is going a step
further it's just voted to make masks
mandatory outdoors in the downtown core
which gets very crowded with tourists
even in the middle of a pandemic heather
urix west
reports nestled in the breathtaking
rocky mountains
banff national park is a treasured
tourist destination
and not even a pandemic is keeping
visitors away
it's a concern that has prompted town
council to adopt an
unusual new bylaw effective friday with
a few exemptions
most visitors will have to wear a mask
not just
indoors but in some outdoor areas too we
believe
at this point that we're the only
municipality in canada
and i don't know beyond that that has
put
a mandatory mass bylaw in place in an
outdoor space
outdoors masks will only be required in
the town's downtown pedestrian zone
an area that has already been closed to
vehicle traffic to allow for physical
distancing
we do have some retailers where there
tends to be some lineups
we have some very popular retailers and
just even when people are going in and
out of stores it can get quite
crowded and squishy by simply creating
this entire zone where people are going
from door to door
continually entering and leaving indoor
spaces that would require a mask
it's far simpler and far safer to not
have those people
frequently adjusting and removing their
masks and then putting a new one back on
banff isn't the only popular tourist
destination dealing with big crowds
this video was taken earlier this month
in niagara falls ontario
days later the region announced a
mandatory mask bylaw for indoor spaces
while outdoors staff have been hired to
educate visitors on the need to maintain
space
and at vancouver's third beach where a
large crowd gathered for a drum circle
last week
there is a new reminder from bc's
provincial health officer to behave
there's a some very stern posters of me
that have been put up to dissuade people
from a congregating in large groups so
maybe that will be effective too
measures taken to allow
summer fun to continue even under the
persistent threat
of kofit 19. heather urex west global
news
calgary the tourism industry around the
world has taken a huge hit from covid19
and we now have a snapshot of the
financial impact
the united nations world tourism
organization says the tourism industry
lost more than 420
billion dollars globally between january
and may
that's more than three times the loss
during the 2009 global economic crisis
in may alone international tourism fell
by 98
compared to last year well if you can
work from home but are looking for a
change of scenery
barbados has an offer for you the island
nation is launching international visas
that allow foreigners to live and work
remotely from barbados during the
pandemic
the barbados welcome stamp is good for
one year
with some conditions your salary must be
above 66
000 a year you need to have your own
health insurance
and there's a non-refundable application
fee up to four thousand dollars barbados
has just
over 100 confirmed cases of kobit 19.
an unprecedented homecoming in halifax
coming up
hmcs fredericton returns after a tragic
trip
overseas plus deleted the viral video
full of fiction about covid19
what a sweet surprise for this lucky
sailor hmcs fredericton returned home to
halifax today after six months at sea
a long time to be away from loved ones
that first kiss wasn't the only moving
moment for those who came home from
operation reassurance
the nato-led mission will forever be
remembered for a deadly cyclone
helicopter crash off the coast of greece
six crew members of hmcs fredericton
were killed
and as ross lord reports it made today's
homecoming bittersweet
for these navy sailors six months has
made a world of difference
after they sailed off to the
mediterranean sea the global pandemic
struck
restricting their movements were not
going ashore no more that was
that was a morale buster right there and
a tougher gut check was coming
on april 29th the ship's helicopter
crashed into the ocean
killing all six people on board our crew
was just totally amazing phenomenal
and we had each other's backs and we
kept each other going the crash happened
close enough to the ship for some
sailors to witness but the frigate
continued on with this mission with the
same crew
for another three months before finally
turning for home
we embarked a padre
we embarked two social workers and
executed a very robust plan
of interviewing the ship's company and
affording them access to those mental
health
resources for three months families of
the deceased have been reflecting on the
lives that were lost
some lieutenant abigail cobra's father
who himself serves in the navy
says his daughter loved adventure riding
motorcycles was a
passion and a hobby watching her player
bagpipes
would be something i had to miss but
then there's the more personal items you
know walking her down the aisle when she
decides to get married
first child those types of things that
just
won't ever happen
for others a long absence means a long
embrace
even if emotional reunions were moved to
a separate location to avoid
overcrowding
we've all been working together in our
own little quarantine world right and
now now we're back in the real world
it's been a long six months yeah it's uh
with covet hitting and everything else
and not having family around
it's been it's been a challenge but he's
home
hopefully for a long time now still
making adjustments but
at least they're home ross lord global
news
halifax
scholarship or stunt still ahead how
facebook is partnering with a canadian
university to fight hate
online
an ontario teenager has pleaded guilty
to terrorism charges relating to a bomb
plot in the name of the so-called
islamic state
the 17 year old originally from syria
was arrested in january of last year he
was 16 at the time and can't be
identified because he's still a minor
the plot involved a plan to use a
pressure cooker
bombed to target bars and nightclubs as
well as members of the police and the
military
canadian authorities learned of the plot
after an undercover informant
tipped off the fbi an ontario university
has teamed up with facebook to try to
stop the spread of hate online
ontario's tech university is tasked by
facebook canada to spot online hate and
misinformation
and to develop strategies and tools to
counter it the university's global
network against hate will receive five
hundred thousand dollars over five years
professor barbara perry says it's a good
start but that facebook
has a long way to go
you know are they doing enough no
they're absolutely not doing enough we
will continue to
to push and i think that's part of what
this relationship is about is
you know providing the information that
uh
facebook needs to move forward and
continuing to to apply pressure
uh and to urge them to make the kinds of
changes that need to be made
uh in terms of both their human capacity
and their technological capacity for
responding
dangerous misinformation still gets
shared millions of times on social media
often
unchecked today facebook twitter and
youtube did remove a video but only
after it went viral
it shows a group of people in lab coats
who call themselves america's
front line doctors because there's a lot
of inaccuracies with the testing
and also even if the test the video
published by right-wing media outlet
breitbart news was shared millions of
times including by president trump
before it was taken down
it claimed falsely that the anti-malaria
drug hydroxychloroquine is a cure for
covid
and that you don't need a mask to slow
the spread of the novel coronavirus next
an orca nbc gives scientists something
to celebrate after a heartbreaking loss
[Music]
russian scientists are digging to find
the rest of this woolly mammoth skeleton
locals discovered the bones near a
siberian lake some parts still have soft
tissue intact which is remarkable
because the woolly mammoths went extinct
some 10 000 years ago
there's been a dramatic rise in
temperature in siberia recently that's
melting the permafrost
and revealing these ancient skeletons
and you may remember the orca j-35 she
was the endangered southern resident
killer whale who
two years ago carried her dead calf for
17 days
it's a story that show the powerful bond
between a mother and baby
as jennifer palmer reports that orca is
now pregnant again
and she's not the only one it's a
picture that's led to a lot of
excitement an
indication an endangered family is
getting ready to grow
we're very excited about it j-35 also
known as telequa
is the mother orca who made
international headlines in 2018 when she
carried her dead calf around the ocean
for 17 days
traveling more than 1600 kilometers
there's been interest in them for 30
and 40 years dr lance barrett leonard
director of the marine mammal research
program with oceanwise
says it's not unusual for orcas to do
this for a short period of time but
j-35's apparent tour of grief shows her
emotional attachment to her calf
j-35 is now 22 years old she also has
another calf
the one she's carrying now is expected
to arrive next year
they have suffered unusually high
mortality in the last few years
and so they've got to make it up with
reproduction so
you know every calf that's born and
there's only been a trickle of them over
the last few years we
watch with great interest researchers
are keeping a keen
eye on southern resident killer whales
because their population is in a
critical state
there's only 73 of them remaining and
their gestation periods are
long lasting up to 17 months so every
pregnancy
is important scientists say there are
three things
threatening them contaminants underwater
vessel noise and lack of food in
particular
chinook salmon they struggle to get
enough food
and we know from the collaborative work
done between the canadian
researchers myself and my colleagues in
the u.s
that the southern residents are
consistently thin but there's another
glimmer of hope
researchers have found another orca l-72
who is also expecting
both pregnancies being watched carefully
not just by researchers
but by their own pods calves and mothers
spend their lives
together it's a testimony really to how
resilient they are that they're that
they're still around now
jennifer palma global news vancouver
and that is global national for this
tuesday i'm donna friesen tonight's your
canada is stanley nova scotia about an
hour north of halifax beautiful sunset
we'd love to see your canada please
email it to viewers at
globalnational.com
thanks for watching hope to see you here
again tomorrow take care of yourselves
bye-bye
[Music]
you